when i think about the storyline or try
and explain it to someone
and be like this guy like trying to go
but let's get out of the house
[Laughter]
so wait i need to read it again
i just want to say what a year for both
of you
two bafta e rising salmon nations two
bafta best actor nominations
and two nominations for that award other
award ceremony that's not as important
as this one
um just want to start off right at the
beginning
though kind of it seems like that
perhaps this is a breakout year for both
of you but there's been a lot of hard
work
for many years along the way did acting
find you or did you seek it out
all right um yeah it kind of found me
yeah it's spit i was being uh can you
swear
can we swear is that we allowed to sweat
do whatever you want free space
yeah yeah that was a [ __ ] uh so i was
the [ __ ] at school so then it kind of so
a teacher told my mum
like you should get out of your system
and um
and then i did writing as a kid so it
was kind of like just i just did stuff
and i was like and then
am i the opportunity and the shares um
to do improv and then i did that and i
was like oh i like this
and then i saw people making money i was
like what
so i was like cool let's try this and
then i just fell in i just fell in love
with it so it kind of was just
really natural yeah as
i guess same for me in some ways um
i my mom had had been an actress and i
had a grandfather who's a screenwriter
so
um i had done it a little bit uh
growing up but what really was the
impetus for me was getting to a
performing arts high school in new york
called laguardia and i just i remember
being 13 on the first day of drama class
really falling in love with it and
seeing how much fun it was and you know
the
the more the more seriously you took it
the better you got at it
daniel i guess with a lot of the
audience here growing up here we um
would have seen you on
skins and also that was a training
ground bing huh
i know bing is black mirror right yeah
yeah i'm sorry
that's right yeah um with
skin's a training ground not only as an
actor but also for you as a writer
yeah um what kind of what how did skins
come about
um i just kind of like either my agent
was funny it's a funny dude
they were dodgy and then um so i was
like well i've got to do my own thing
and then uh and i just started writing
plays and uh
and acting and directing them at heating
like theater company and have sophia
it doesn't really exist anymore and then
like and then
skins were looking for young writers and
so i got skins it was me
dev and kyle were at the same open
audition in holloway
we was all there and then um they found
us just like we did that and then i
joined as a writer and it was just that
kind of
yeah we just do it it was like people
that went to the open audition were
already doing
it extracurricular like doing
extracurricular activities so they were
into it
so no one was really trying to get like
because it was an e4 show
like e4 those times showed friends and
scrubs like
it wasn't a serious channel like so he
was just doing
like he was like how does his channel
like do we want so
like we just did what we wanted and uh
and then it just became a became a thing
out here
what was your kind of first for your
first break into the world of acting
uh you know there's two that i keep in
my head one was a commercial i did when
i was
10 years old for disney or disneyland i
guess
i went down to florida to the theme park
and uh
it's funny they had three kids cast
there's like an american version and i
had to do the french canadian version
so that was my first dialect work they
had me memorize how to say
what an awesome vacation but with a
canadian accent in french
and the other one as as it is for a lot
of actors in new york
the mothership it's a law order that was
like my first
uh like real acting gig and i got my
throat
slit and then anthony anderson comes up
to my body and he's like that's a dead
body
and uh so that's my first time yeah
the first corpse um first course
forgetting obviously to get out and call
me by your name
both astonishing films but both
essentially
small indies when they started out um
let's start with kind of call me by your
name how did you come on board to the
project and how long was it before i
kind of even got to that
stage of making it yeah well i was 17
years old i met with luca guadagnino for
the first time that's the director of
the film
and um and that was really by luck of
the universe i mean i didn't have the
acting credits really yet to justify
that kind of meeting but
my agent brian schwarzer represented
tilda swinton who's the lead of
a lot of luca's other movies so when
this project came around i could kind of
i was presented for a meeting with him
as someone that could maybe play this
role
and luca historically doesn't like to
audition as actors so he said
you're attached but it felt like you
know
hopefully this comes together but that
summer it didn't the summer after it
didn't
the summer after that it didn't too so i
thought you know i don't know if it's
ever gonna happen
but then when i was 20 years old in like
the span of months it really rapidly
came together and i was thankful it took
like that amount of time i think if i
did it when i was 17 or 18
well i don't know if i could have done
it at 17. i don't would have been legal
to do it at 17
but like if i you know doing it later
just having a couple more years of
experience being able to
be a little bit more calm like daniel
and i did an interview a couple months
ago
and i'm like very proud to be up here
right now i'm not like bouncing all over
the place because the first time we did
it together i was like
tense so this was part of my interview
as well was before kind of both these
films would be no
get out had been released but i don't
think calling by your name had been
released
at that point um playing elio
um he is kind of a renaissance teenager
in a way
um what was your research process and
tim did you read the book and also kind
of
you don't remember the 80s but your
experience of being a teenager
in the 80s it's so nuanced in particular
which you know it's captured so well
right what how did you go about well
yeah like you said it's the
the book and the book becomes like a
bible of sorts and for those that have
read the book it's fiercely from the
point of view of elio so
there's just so much to pull from and
there's there's a lot of background
information
and then as you you know pointed out too
there's a lot of piano playing and
i had to learn italian for that too so
there was a you know about a month and a
half two months of uh
of a background research going into it
and um and when it comes time to do it
you just try to let that all go and
do the best job you can get out
um jordan peele's script when it first
came to you kind of
what was it like on paper in terms of
trying to make it genre specific it's
not i would say it's like
magical realism with a bit of horror
with a thriller
like an exploration of race relations
does that all come out
at you on the page straight away or you
like
i'm not quite sure what this is no it
did it did it was all
there like it's just for me i kind of
read scripts and go
does do i feel like the writer knows it
i mean that's my thing it's like you
kind of don't really need to know the
details because
do they know the world does it speak to
because i've got
like and i've got good friends around me
that are good [ __ ] detectives like
when they watch films
so like nah that doesn't make sense that
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
so i always see
scripts from their angle because does it
make sense and if it makes sense that
means they've done the work
so um so i kind of felt like and then it
just spoke to me
because it spoke to me because i've been
a black man at that point
at that party so it's um yeah it was
just
and there was elements that were surreal
but because he knew the world
it didn't it didn't matter which i mean
it's like it's grounded but there's
just otherworldly things like brain
surgeries and stuff like that so
it was um yeah i knew he did the work
and it just
it just tapped into something and it was
like unapologetic which was i find
really exciting
um were you kind of was was there ever a
hesitation of taking on the role or did
you from reading it going i know
this is the person i want to play chris
i want to do this role
or was there kind of a level of
nervousness kind of jumping into it
i knew jordan was gonna get in trouble
like i was like you're gonna get in
trouble
i like trouble man
that's what we're here for though like i
don't know this [ __ ] [ __ ] man
i i i kind of like cool if at least i'm
going to go down
doing something i believe in if it goes
wrong because anything can go wrong
and so it's just about stuff that if i
believe in it then i'll go
i can stand by that john saying and i'll
go because that's the script that could
go wrong
in the wrong hands i mean and so
there was just that so i read it i
remember and there but there were
moments of doubts i'm like
when i really wanted it or when i got it
i'd read it again and i go am i crazy
like when i think about the storyline or
try and explain it to someone
and be like this guy like he's trying to
go but let's get out of the house
[Laughter]
wait i need to read it again i read it
like four times before i even started
shooting like
before we started rehearsing and then i
was like oh you know it's all right i
like it i like it i still like it
um so it was a lot of a lot of um
a lot that but i think that's normal i
think anything that you're because i'm
putting my face on so same with like
coming right you're putting your
you're putting yourself out there so you
have to be doubly sure about but
usually the first decision is the right
one and then just the world comes in and
compromises you i thought it was
fascinating when you said that jordan
really wanted to cast you but the only
thing he was nervous about was that you
weren't american and that you were that
you were british
yeah so it was that there was a lot of
that kind of like
because i think in america they don't
really know about stuff that happens
outside of america
i'm getting trouble today
it's gonna be a long week
yeah yeah but so basically like i just
basically he didn't know he didn't know
the black british
experience so because a lot of people
don't i think a lot of people in england
though
so then like so then he just asked me a
couple questions i was like yeah yeah i
know i know what's happening um
[Music]
so